[Music]
on this monday night
lebanon sinks deeper into turmoil
while the entire government has just
quit politicians the corruption
they've been here since the civil war
and who could take the reins of a
country
hanging in the balance from chinese
government critics to accused criminals
beijing's apparent new attempts to
silence the pro-democracy movement
technology to detect tornadoes
the criticism that canada lags behind
and hand crafting history i feel
my ancestors are here with me a
tradition almost lost to a shameful part
of canada's past
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
farah nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
the catastrophic explosion that ripped
through beirut nearly one week ago
has now rocked lebanon's political
establishment
today the country's prime minister
resigned along with the entire cabinet
hassan the ab who had only been in
office since january said the disaster
was a direct result
of systemic state corruption the fury
over the explosion and the deaths of at
least 160 people
drove residents to the streets for a
third day in revolt against lebanon's
political elites
and government dysfunction even before
the blast
it was a nation facing skyrocketing
poverty and a deepening economic crisis
made even worse by the covid19 pandemic
crystal commansing on lebanon's
uncertain future
they're now being called revolutionaries
anti-government demonstrators firing
back at police with firecrackers or
anything on hand it is a dangerous power
struggle
and the government cracked madness
prime minister hassan diab resigning
saying
we take a step back to stand with the
people to undergo this battle of change
with them we want to open the door
towards national salvation
he called out corruption and the
political elites blaming them for the
deadly blast at the port
people are demanding an emergency
transitional government take over
and address dire basic needs the beirut
explosion
was like 15 years of war in 15 seconds
these were our darkest 15 seconds
we have never seen this amount of human
loss physical damage and shattered lives
in such a short time
u.n officials gathered virtually to
strategize and call for an
independent investigation into the blast
the meeting taking place
before the lebanese government resigned
but many
anticipated the move it is also
important that reforms be implemented so
as to address the needs of the lebanese
people for the longer term
it's the international community
providing the people of beirut with a
lifeline
one possible name being raised as a
replacement for diab
is a well-known judge on the
international court noah salaam
another zad harari he vacated the
position in january but resigned in
october 2019
because of the collapse of the economy
he stayed on until his successor was
appointed
the app has been asked to stay on until
a new cabinet is formed
the outgoing cabinet is controlled by
hezbollah
a political group in lebanon and
according to many governments
including canada's a terrorist
organization
while people wait for a new cabinet to
be formed one thing is certain
average citizens are doing the heavy
lifting to restore their lives
crystal gomencing global news london
to another country in political turmoil
belarus
where there is a dispute over the
results of the presidential election
and specifically claims the vote was
rigged to keep the country's long-ruling
leader in power
tonight concerns as to the whereabouts
of his opponent
in the capitol police violently cracked
down on demonstrators who took to the
streets to protest sunday's results
president alexander lupachenko accused
the protesters of being sheep
controlled from abroad the 65 year old
claimed a landslide victory with a
reported 80 percent of the vote
his widely popular rival 37 year old
teacher
svetlana tikanovskaya is refusing to
accept the results
there are now reports she has not been
seen since a meeting at the election
commission late today
lukashenko is accused of human rights
abuses and silencing his critics
he's held power in the former soviet
republic for 26 years
to hong kong next where beijing appears
to have taken further steps
to crack down on the pro-democracy
movement
police in the city have made a number of
arrests including taking
high-profile newspaper owner jimmy ly
into custody
he's been a vocal supporter of
anti-government protests
and all this comes as relations between
beijing and the west worsen
with china imposing sanctions on u.s
politicians
and criticizing canada and its allies
redmond shannon reports
two arrests from two generations of
activists
in one day billionaire and media mogul
jimmy ly
handcuffed and escorted through his
newspaper offices
on monday morning police say he's
charged with colluding with a foreign
power
a crime under hong kong's new national
security laws introduced
six weeks ago lai has met with a number
of u.s lawmakers
including vice president mike pence the
71 year old also faces a charge of fraud
unrelated to national security that's
all about
the individual behaviors nothing about
the company itself
but his company's newspaper apple daily
has been
highly critical of the hong kong and
beijing governments
officers removed evidence from the
building and made ten other arrests
including young democracy campaigner
agnes chao
one or two friends of mine have
contacted me
and they are very very worried that i
would be arrested tonight
emily lau has been a pro-democracy voice
for decades
some people have said to me today that
they are very concerned
that some of the people arrested could
actually be sent
to mainland china lau says these changes
are difficult to stop now
but urges the west to continue
pressuring china
beijing imposed sanctions on 11 american
critics of china
on monday
including senators marco rubio and ted
cruz and
the heads of some ngos it was a response
to washington
freezing the u.s assets of 11 chinese
and hong kong officials
including the city's leader kari lam on
monday two
china's embassy in ottawa called western
criticism
typical double standards the rising
tensions come as canadians michael
kovrig and michael spavor
are marking more than 600 days in a
chinese
prison charged with spying and as huawei
executive mong wong
zhou awaits extradition from canada to
the u.s
to face a fraud trial redmond shannon
global news london
turning to the covet 19 crisis now
health officials in manitoba say the
province is seeing early indications
of community transmission 16 new cases
were recorded today and that follows
yesterday's jump of 35.
ontario also saw numbers rise today for
the first time in more than a week the
province is reporting more than 100 new
cases
and quebec registered 98 new cases today
the first time in a month that province
has dropped below
100 new cases and quebec has updated its
back to school plan
its education minister says the new
strategy aims to make communication
between teachers and students as easy as
possible
the province will now require students
grade 5 and up to our masks in all
common areas of school buildings but not
in the classroom students will stay with
the same classmates
all day with no physical distancing
required
while they are in class and there is
some positive news when it comes to
schools
and businesses come the fall new
modeling suggests the country could get
through a second wave of covet 19
without having to shut down but data
published in today's canadian medical
association journal
is also raising some eyebrows heather
urex west looks at what the next few
months
could look like a new school year
usually brings a mix of anxiety
and excitement but the nerves this year
are unlike any year before
i'm very worried about the fact that
inside the classroom there is no
physical distancing anymore and there
are no masks
across the country parents have had to
add masks and hand sanitizer to their
school supply shopping lists
as schools prepare to reopen the next
wave of infections is coming
and according to new models we may be
able to keep the number of infections in
check
without shutting schools and businesses
back down
a lot of the heavy lifting is done by
the physical distancing measures
and when physical distancing is applied
and if it's adhered to it can really
reduce
transmission the modeling found without
continued public health measures kofit
19 cases would surge
well beyond hospital capacity through
the fall and into
the new year maintaining physical
distancing lowers the numbers but not
enough to keep hospitals from being
overwhelmed
it's only when physical distancing is
combined with enhanced testing
and contact tracing that the curve is
flattened enough to allow
hospitals to cope and this is without
any community closures
the model found that keeping schools
closed could actually
increase hospital admissions from 16 to
19 per 100 000
because it results in higher
transmission at home
i think it's encouraging it is possible
to keep numbers in check
without massive and full closures but
that's based on us
continuing what we're doing today and
not having any lapses or
or additional covet fatigue that leads
to larger numbers or outbreaks
which could be a tall order as the
pandemic stretches
the institute of investigative
journalism has already seen an
increase in kovid 19 cases linked to
bars restaurants and day cares over the
summer
beginning in about june we started to
notice an uptick
in infections in public places
in late june and that increased quite a
bit
which begs the question what happens
next when schools reopen
and colder weather sets in heather urex
west global news
calgary another controversy for the
trudeau liberals
coming up why the commercial rent relief
program is under
new scrutiny
the liberal government is defending its
decision to have a crown corporation
oversee a rent relief program for small
businesses
even though it was then farmed out to a
private firm
and in a familiar twist that firm has
some
liberal connections michael couture
joins us from ottawa and mike once again
opposition parties want answers yeah
farah two separate letters are being
sent to the lobbying commissioner and
the ethics commissioner
from two opposition mps asking if two
government contracts were awarded
because of alleged liberal cronyism the
latest is related to the 85
84 million kennedy emergency commercial
rent assistance program that program
was being run by the canada mortgage and
housing corporation or cmhc
however according to the government the
crown corporation decided to have an
outside firm administer the program
the senior vice president of that firm
is rob silver the spouse to prime
minister justin trudeau's chief of staff
katie telford now the prime minister's
office said that telford
proactively reached out to the office of
the conflict of interest and ethics
commissioner in january
before silver was even hired she was
told
everything was okay pmo says telford
also set up a voluntary ethics screen
just in case and recused herself from
any decisions pertaining to that program
that was more than prime minister justin
trudeau did with the awarding of the
proposed
student services grant contract to we
charity now the conservatives say
the awarding of that rent subsidy
contract could all be a coincidence
but they want it investigated in fact
the prime minister
and his government directed it again to
an outside corporation
suggests that they were trying to feed
the pork
to a favored recipient mike let's move
on now to the weed charity controversy
because today
members of the house of commons finance
committee got documents they had asked
for related to the weed charity
controversy
what could we learn from those documents
yeah so this weekend the liberals turned
over more than
5 000 pages of documents which should
shed more light
into the decision-making process behind
the awarding of the canada student
services grant to we charity we'll talk
we are told that lawyers from the public
service
are pouring over them to redact any
references to cabinet confidence
and we charity controversy will continue
to be in the spotlight this week pharah
as two more cabinet ministers are set to
be grilled at the finance committee
we'll be watching michael couture in
ottawa thank you mike
police in ottawa are investigating an
incident outside the office of liberal
mp catherine mckenna
police aren't commenting on the
investigation but a video that surfaced
on social media over the weekend
appears to show a man asking to speak
with mckenna
and then hurling obscenities at an
office staffer
i saw it for the first time on social
media someone hurling abuses
completely unacceptable abuses
threatening my staff member
like look i think the canadians don't
want this but we can't stand for it and
we need to be vigilant
this isn't the first time the minister
has been targeted mckenna's office was
spray painted with a
vulgar slur just days after she was
re-elected
last year the ontario human rights
commission has released some
highly disturbing findings on racial
profiling and discrimination
within the toronto police service in a
new report the commission says it
analyzed police data
from 2013 to 2017 and it found
that black people are more likely than
others to be arrested
charged overcharged struck shot or
killed
by toronto police according to the
report black people make up 8.8
percent of toronto's population yet they
account for nearly one-third of all
charges in the data set
this is the commission's second interim
report in its inquiry into
anti-bloc profiling and discrimination
by toronto
police in a statement today the force
said it views the report
as vitally important and it's committed
to change still ahead the towering ash
clouds is an indonesian volcano erupts
once again
you're watching global national
indonesia's mount cineben erupted again
today launching a huge column of ash
five kilometers into the sky this is the
second
eruption since saturday and officials
are warning about the threat of lava
the once dormant volcano has been active
since 2010.
two teens were tragically killed last
week when they were caught by a powerful
tornado in western manitoba
it somehow arrived with little warning
despite key
signs of fierce weather beforehand as
eric sorensen reports it begs the
question
just how effective and outdated are
canada's tornado alert systems
it was a ferocious tornado that swept
down swiftly and with little warning in
southern manitoba
two lives were lost and the question is
whether warnings could have been quicker
or more specific to the tornado's path
it just seemed all so
unreal and it was quick and you know
i saw it starting and my the very first
thing i did was i went to
tornado chasers page to see if there's
any warnings there were warnings
on friday environment canada issued
severe thunderstorm warnings for
southwestern manitoba
about two hours before the tornado
appeared at 7
49 pm a tornado warning was issued for
the rural municipality of sifton
just minutes later southwest of scarth
around 8 p.m
the tornado touched down and tracked for
several kilometers
toward the regional municipality they
had the tornado warning out
as early as they possibly could have
based on radar
the rotation was just showing up as the
spotter reports
were saying that this is touching down
while the alerts were quick
the area warned was vast the regional
municipality of sifton covers more than
760 square kilometers
more than a decade ago the u.s weather
service changed from broad
county-based warnings to specific
storm-based tracking
covering narrow areas the u.s warnings
can alert more accurately the people
that are in the path of a tornado
and the u.s is now upgrading that to
track tornadoes and severe rotations
in real time we'll be able to provide
more quickly and timely updated
information
that people can leverage you know on
their smartphone or
some other device where they can see how
the probabilities will increase
and affect them canada is behind the u.s
and storm watchers here think it's time
ottawa invested in upgrades
to canada's tornado tracking technology
as opposed to a giant county based
warning you can you could
potentially have a warning that that
isolates exactly where the rotation is
on that storm i mean tornadoes are
incredibly isolated
i think it would be very very a very
very good step for environment canada
to upgrade to storm-based warnings
canada 2 is implementing cell phone
alerts all the more important that
future technology narrows the actual
threat location
so that warnings don't go to tens of
thousands of people who aren't anywhere
close to the path of the tornado
eric sorensen global news toronto
a disaster is escalating off east africa
as crews
raced to empty the leaking oil tanker
near mauritius
large cracks have appeared on the
stranded japanese ship
experts say it's likely to split apart
in the next two days dumping an
estimated
2500 tons of fuel into the indian ocean
the ship ran aground on july 25th
up next the master craftsman who's
working to keep migma tradition afloat
in nova scotia this fall a new boat will
launch
taking pieces of the land onto the water
the 21-foot canoe is being entirely
built out of materials from unseated
migma territory it's a sacred indigenous
craft
that's keeping a master craftsman
connected to his ancestors
alexa mclean has his story when i'm here
alone
is just the wind in the water i feel my
ancestors are here with me
and very happy to see this happening
nestled in the sacred mikmah grounds of
kejimakujik
national park todd labrador immerses
himself in a traditional craft his
great-grandfather used
to feed his family birchbark canoe
building is not
common in the mi'kmaq community i'm one
of the few builders
i didn't plan it that way his
great-grandfather joe germany was born
in 1884.
labrador says if it wasn't for him
protecting his father from being forced
into a residential school
the family would have lost their
cultural connection
when a black car came on the reservation
all the kids would run
so dad and his siblings would run and
hide in the woods sometimes for days
great grandfather would hide him out in
the woods labrador's father told him
stories of his great grandfather's craft
and how it was used you take a birchbark
canoe and love
and you can put hundreds of pounds of
whatever you have
and then transport transported across
quite easily paddling to
across the bay of fundy paddling to
newfoundland
the majority of materials labrador uses
to build these
mighty rough water canoes he harvests
from the surrounding land
i might dig 400 feet of this
from the forest in collaboration with
parks canada the labrador is building
this 21 foot
birch bark canoe out of this shop in
keji
i really encourage nova scotian
residents
visitors to nova scotia this summer to
take advantage of this phenomenal
opportunity that is perfectly in fact
set up
for a physical distancing experience
surrounded by photos of the man who
paved the way to this
craft labrador has shared this labor of
love with others who want to learn the
craft
including mickmah youth from bear river
first nation
labrador plans to launch the canoe this
fall
alexa mclean global news halifax
and that is global national for this
monday i'm farah nasser
we leave you tonight with some bungara
on the beach
popular yukon dancer gurdeep pander has
been visiting british columbia and is
spreading joy wherever he goes
the beaches near tofino are no exception
thank you so much for watching until
tomorrow
take care of yourselves and each other
good night
[Music]